au cinquième jour de l'invasion russe le
sort du dombass est toujours incertain
la bataille se concentre autour de la
ville de sya verrou donetsk les russes
tentent de couper le ravitaillement des
forces du crânienne qui résistent par
tous les moyens comme ici au bord de
cette route stratégique à une
cinquantaine de kilomètres plus au sud
le
cratère est trop petit pour une frappe
aérienne
cela ressemble plus à un cratère
d'environ il lance roquettes
selon kiev sylvie rodeau niet ce qui est
passée en grande partie sous le contrôle
de moscou et des forces séparatistes
mais les combats font toujours rage
pour résumer la situation sur les
théâtres d'opérations principaux
l'agresseur poursuit l'offensive et ses
forces dans cercle et nos troupes dans
la région de ces vers donesk ellis
island sq ainsi que de bloquer les
principales routes logistique
frappes aériennes tirs d'artillerie
déploiement d'un nombre croissant de
troupes les russes et leurs alliés mise
tout sur le contrôle de cette ville au
prix de grandes destructions comme en
attestent ces images satellites les
positions qui leur permettent de
bombarder massivement la ville voisine
de l'iscid shank de l'autre côté du
fleuve les forces du craignait ne
s'attendent aussi à ce que moscou
utilisent des missiles de longue portée
pour frapper si les rhodaniennes sq et
ses environs